From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Hello, Pedro.
Today is Wednesday, July 6, 2011.
My name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Wall of the History Program at the University of North Carolina UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill.
I'm in Greensboro, North Carolina with the out of Rick John Bishop.
We are here to conduct an interview in the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the National Museum of African-American History and Culture inside the Smithsonian Institution and the Library of Congress.
We're on the campus of Bennett College with Provost Esther Terry and Dr. Terri, it's just a privilege to be with you.
Thank you for sitting now with us.
Thank you for having me.
I'm going to bring some time on. I know you're very busy schedule. It's really nice to be with you.
I thought we'd start today if you would, but maybe just a description of your family and life as a child of a war in California to range across that.
Yes, it was a wonderful time.
I am the youngest of 12.
So I always, always, from the time I opened my eyes, had many hands around to pick me up when I fell, to punch me out sometimes when we had one day wanted to show that they were all bigger and stronger and so much growner than I was.
But it was a good life. We were farmers.
My dad was Mary Alexander. My mom was Mary Alexander. My mom had gone through, had started to enter normal school.
In those days, that was where one went, many, many women went to prepare to come back, to teach to the community.
My mom had gotten to normal school, but after her first year there, her mom died.
And she was the oldest of her siblings, so she was brought home to take care of them.
That was an unfortunate thing because she always, always wanted to go finish and to teach.
But she didn't, and she married my father as a second husband. Her first husband died in the flu epidemic of 1917.
My mom was married and to author Hunt, and they had three children.
She lived with author and her three children in Richmond, Virginia. She actually was born in Warren County, North Carolina as well.
She had left Warren County, North Carolina with her husband, and they had taken a residence in Richmond, Virginia.
He died of the flu.
Meanwhile, my dad, who had grown up in Virginia right across the line, if you know where my home is, is right on the border of Virginia.
My father had married a wife, and he had three children as well.
He lost his wife in that epidemic and his three children.
My mom lost her husband, but her three children survived. So she moved home as one was want to do.
It was a thing to do. She moved home now. She was a woman with three children to raise, and no husband.
So she moved back to her home in Warren County, North Carolina, and she met my dad.
And they were married. They met him were married. And he then started to share crop, and she went to the farm with him.
He raised all of those children, her three children as his own. And to that union, as they say, they were nine more children born.
So I actually am the youngest of 12 children, all of us were my mother's children.
But actually all of us were my dad's children too, because he loved us all. And that we grew up there as a family on a big old farm that my dad worked for in the early years as a sharecropper, but soon decided to work with the owner to try to buy.
And did succeeded in buying the land. And that land has remained in our family from from the time there. My dad died in 1970, and mom died in 1985.
And we have kept the land. Now I regret to say all of my siblings are dead. I'm the last of them.
So the farm means a great deal to me in North, that farm in, in Wise, North Carolina, North Carolina, because I choose where I am in Wise, North Carolina, North Carolina, the farm.
And the children there are nieces and nephews. They are the children of my brothers and sisters. And so as we did when one sibling was out of place, when they were living, the other siblings looked after the children.
So I only have one son, biologically speaking, but I have a lot of children when you consider all of the nieces and nephews and their children and their children's children. So we are many.
When Mr. Father is able to make that purchase?
In 1945, I think, in 1945, dad made that.
What about schooling and church when you were a child?
Well, very important. The church, particularly.
My mom was a serious, serious churchgoer. But she wasn't fanatic about that. And so we had the teachings of the church. More than the preachings, I think.
Can I make those, those, that distinction? I think my mom always said to us when she wanted us to be good, good children.
She would say, I'd rather see a sermon than to hear one. That was her philosophy. My mom wasn't interested so much.
I mean, we went to church daily, regularly, not daily, but regularly. When it was time for us to go, every time for us to go to church, we went to church.
But it was, it wasn't oppressive church. She understood if we kind of sat with the girls our age and giggled a little bit. She understood if we were our age.
She didn't make us, she didn't make us burdened by the church, but she always wanted us to be good. And so she paid more attention to how going to Sunday school than to hear preaching so much.
But Sunday school was important. We learned, we learned a lot. And she would ask us when we came home from Sunday school, what did you learn?
And she always asked us to apply that to our lives. My mom was always, we used to call her the, how would you feel if mom, you know, behind her back, of course, we never said anything like that in the fun of our face.
She would always say, if we, you know, did something, she didn't think was nice. She would say to someone else, how would you feel if that happened to you and she'd make us think about it?
How would you feel if someone took your lunch? How would you feel if someone walked away from you and kept you from playing?
We learned early, and I don't know where we learned it, but one of the things we did that I often think about, you know, I asked myself, is it an eight, you know?
We learned that separation was painful. If, for instance, if we were without a little girlfriend and we weren't allowed to fight, we never did that.
But we learned very early that if we said, don't play with Sally, or we, or, you know, we get the group on my side against Sally.
We're not going to play with her. That's how it would hurt so badly. I don't know how we learned that isolation was such a powerful tool to use against someone.
But we did. And my mom would always say, how would you feel if somebody did that to you? How would you feel if somebody did that to you?
So we used to call her, or how would you feel if we never tell her that?
What was the school experience that you had as a child?
Oh, we excelled in school. I liked school. I always did. My sisters and brothers, I really, I don't know that they liked school as much as I did.
But we went because my mom, you see, thought it was important for us to go to school. And because we worked on a farm, we weren't always allowed to go every day.
Sometimes the crops would just need to be taken in. You know, we just needed to save the crops. But mom would work so very, very hard to do all of it.
To make up for our not being in the field. She would get up in the morning and go to the field with my dad.
And she would work. Oh, she would work so hard. She'd pick cotton. What a terrible thing to do pick. But she would pick cotton. She would pick cotton.
To make up for the fact that we weren't there. And then we were told to come from school directly from school and change our clothes really, really quickly and run, run, run to the field to because mom would be there working so hard.
And then when we got to the field to help pick the cotton, she would go to the house to make us something good for supper. She always did good supper for us.
I had a good life. I didn't know I was a poor girl. I didn't think about that too much.
How closely connected was the black community in the area of Wise, North Carolina? Because of course farmland sketch can be depending on population. That's fairly spread out.
Well, there were. But but you see we had the church and we had the school. They they were centers for the activity of the community.
And we we took advantage of those my my parents would come to school for for Easter programs. They would come for programs that we had in the evenings where their children, you know, performed and they saw their children. My parents were very much as were the parents of other members in the community very much involved with the school.
Not like now, not so much so is that the case now as I think about it as I go home to see. But when I grew up parents were very much involved in in the school of very much.
Sometimes we did and sometimes we didn't. I think the times when we didn't was when my brothers were away and not we didn't have a brother to drive.
And my dad didn't ever drive. He never ever drove and I don't know why that was but he just never drove a car. Never was licensed. But if when my brothers were there before they would go off to the army or go somewhere we would have a car.
I just suggested something I was interested. I know there are 11 siblings ahead of you. But in broad one one very important part about about your life history courses you're the first in your family to go to four year college.
Yes.
And what were the life paths of taken by some of your older siblings?
Oh, we didn't have money to go to college. I like to talk about this part of it. I'm not very much willing and coming forth coming to talking about my family very much. But I always want to say that I always thought how ironic.
I thought always that I was not the smartest of my siblings. I was just the luckiest one in this regard. There was never money. There weren't many scholarships you know then as there are now for black kids to go off to school.
So my brothers and sisters will go up and they went off. We had a thriving much more thriving than now manufacturing country then. Manufacturing was big and so they got job in factories. One of my brothers worked two of my brothers worked at Ford Motors.
One of them you know my brother I had a brother who would always well he would never drive any car. There wasn't a general motor car and he would always say why didn't you get a general motor car. There were loyal to the factories that they worked in and some of them worked. I had a brother who worked in Newport News, Virginia for a very long time.
For a long time then made a good living. I had another brother who worked in the system, the school system of New York. I think he might have been a janitor. They call him something else now. Engineers of some kind of another thing he was probably just a janitor but he took pride in his job.
And they were proud that they were never fired from anything and they all bought their homes and took care of their wives in that way.
How did it come to pass that your family was able to send you to Bennett?
Well, farmers got social security. It's as simple as that. My sense of these things sometimes when I think about them is that it's so connected and so unknown by people who sit in decision making positions in the world. They don't quite know how one thing affects another.
When did the farmers get social security in 1957? Until that time, farmers did not get social security. They wanted.
When farmers got social security, the recipients of social security were able to get it retroactive to the time that they turned 65.
I remember going home and working so hard, helping my parents. Not just my parents but helping the people in the neighborhood go and sign up to prove their ages. I learned so much about the Bible.
I remember where names were recorded. Most of the people in my community had been born at home with midwives and so the midwife would. Here's another thing. The midwife would have four babies delivered in a week and she'd have to go all the way into town to register them.
I would go to the baby boy and I would turn them all in when I get a lot. There's all kinds of stories that I loved hearing about my folk. That person was not really born on that day. That person was born on another day.
That's how that goes. We had good times talking about how the midwife misnamed somebody or forgot, spelled the name incorrectly. There are those stories.
Everybody knew everybody in my neighborhood. We got together and I learned my first chance to figure out how to convince somebody about your age.
If you don't have it in the courthouse, if you don't have a birth certificate, you should go to the family Bible because most people entered the deaths and births. If you have to go looking for a history of the people, find deaths in births, find a Bible or some other religious place in the Bible. The black community was the Bible.
They could tell you what year a flood came or when a tornado came and killed three kids or these catastrophic in nature, these catastrophic things in nature would be landmarks that would help prove their age.
They could help some people prove that they were at least 65 and it's to establish when they turned 65 so that they could get their checks and begin to get social security.
When my mom said, when my dad got a check, my mom said, this one would go to college. This one actually had no choice to go to college when I think about it. I think I might not have survived. I was so disappointed in her and that would have killed me.
She was so much and only then did I know that she had wanted every single one of those kids to go to school. She engaged with us in the evenings when we did our lessons.
The lessons were very important for us to do and she used to spell with us. One was a terrific speller. She would spell with us, spell our names out.
She would spell anything we'd have contest. We spent a lot of time together as a family.
I'm interested to get a sense as best you can recall this and think about how other persons might have given a description below what you like as a 17-year-old thinking about heading up to college.
But who did you have a set of well-formulated ambitions at that time? Did you know what you wanted to study?
No, I was going to teach. Something is general. I really don't recall. I think you would have asked someone else.
Here's what I don't think I was. I don't think I was as independent of my family as I might have been.
I think I was always maybe too late thinking independent of what my mother needed, what my father needed, and how we would work together.
You see, growing up, we all talked about how we're going to all work and we're going to own the land.
We're going to own the land. So it was always a we that when we talked about the things we were going to do, always at the center of it was we were going to get the land and dad's going to finish paying for the land and then we're going to get a car
and then we're going to get a big house and then we're going to get. So we was propelled there.
It propelled me in my thinking. I think maybe in 17 I didn't think so much about going off to do anything. I knew I was going to teach.
I think. I was going to who I was going to teach and why is of course.
Let's take this a little quick.
Today is Wednesday July 6, 2011. My name is Joe.
Thank you for sitting down with us. Thank you for having me.
For clearing some time on I know you're very busy schedule. It's really nice to be with you.
I thought we'd start today if you were with maybe just a description of your family and life as a child of a war in Germany.
A range across that.
Yes, it was a wonderful time. I am the youngest of 12.
So I always, always from the time I opened my eyes had many hands around to pick me up when I fell, to punch me out sometimes.
You know, when they wanted to show that they were all bigger and stronger and so much growner than I was.
But it was a good life. We were farmers. My dad was Mary Alexander.
And my mom was Mary Alexander. My mom had gone through, had started to enter normal school.
In those days that was where one went, many, many women went to prepare to come back, to teach to the community.
My mom had gotten to normal school, but after her first year there, her mom died.
And she was the oldest of her siblings, so she was brought home to take care of him.
That was an unfortunate thing because she always, always wanted to go finish and to teach.
But she didn't. And she married my father as a second husband.
Her first husband died in the flu epidemic of 1917.
My mom was married and to author hut and they had three children.
She lived with author and her three children in Richmond, Virginia.
She actually was born in Warren County, North Carolina as well. She had left Warren County, North Carolina with her husband.
And they had taken a residence in Richmond, Virginia. He died of the flu.
Meanwhile, my dad, who had grown up in Virginia right across the line, if you know where my home is,
it's right on the border of Virginia.
My father had married a wife and he had three children as well.
He lost his wife in that epidemic and his three children.
My mom lost her husband, but her three children survived.
So she moved home as she was one was want to do.
She moved home now. She was a woman with three children to raise.
And no husband. So she moved back to her home in Warren County, North Carolina.
And she met my dad. And they were married. They met him were married.
And he then started to share crop and she went to the farm with him.
He raised all of those children, her three children as his own.
And he had union as they said that there were nine more children born.
So I actually am the youngest of 12 children, all of us were my mother's children.
But actually all of us were my dad's children too because he loved us all.
And that we grew up there as a family on a big old farm that my dad worked for in the early years as a sharecropper.
But soon decided to work with the owner to try to buy and get succeeded in buying the land.
And that land has remained in our family from the time there.
My dad died in 1970 and mom died in 1985.
And we have kept the land.
Now I regret to say all of my siblings are dead. I'm the last of them.
So the farm means a great deal to me in North that farm in Wise, North Carolina, North Carolina because of actors where I am.
In Wise, North Carolina, North Carolina, the farm.
And the children there are nieces and nephews. They are the children of my brothers and sisters.
And so as we did when one sibling was out of place, when they were living, the other siblings looked after the children.
So I only have one son, biologically speaking.
But I have a lot of children when you consider all of the nieces and nephews and their children and their children.
So we are many.
When Mr. Father Able to make that purchase?
My dad.
It's not a small account.
In 1945 I think. In 1945. Dad made that.
What about schooling and church when you were a child?
Well, very important. The church particularly.
My mom was a serious, serious church goer.
But she wasn't fanatic about that.
And so we had the teachings of the church more than the preachings.
Can I make those that distinction?
I think my mom always said to us when she wanted us to be good children.
She would say, I'd rather see a sermon than to hear one.
That was her philosophy.
Mom wasn't interested so much.
I mean, we went to church daily regularly.
But regularly, when it was time for us to go every time for us to go to church, we went to church.
But it was, it wasn't oppressive church.
She understood if we kind of sat with the girls our age and giggled a little bit.
She understood if we were our age.
She didn't make us, she didn't make us burdened by the church.
But she always wanted us to be good.
And so she paid more attention to how going to Sunday school than to hear preaching so much.
And Sunday school was important.
We learned a lot.
And she would ask us when we came home from Sunday school, what did you learn?
And she always asked us to apply that to our lives.
My mom was always, we used to call her the, how would you feel if mom, you know, behind her back, of course.
We never said anything like that in front of our face.
But she would always say, if we did something, she didn't think was nice.
She would say to someone else, how would you feel if that happened to you?
And she would make us think about it.
How would you feel if someone took your lunch?
How would you feel if someone walked away from you and kept you from playing?
We learned early, and I don't know where we learned it.
But one of the things we did that I often think about, you know, I ask myself, is it innate, you know?
But we learned that separation was painful.
If, for instance, if we were with our little girlfriends and we weren't allowed to fight.
We never did that.
But we learned very early that if we said, don't play with Sally, or we get the group on my side against Sally.
We're not going to play with her, that Sally would hurt so badly.
I don't know how we learned that isolation was such a powerful tool to use against someone.
But we did.
And my mom would always say, how would you feel if somebody did that to you?
How would you feel if somebody did that to you?
So we used to call her, or how would you feel if we didn't have a child in that?
What was the school experience that you had as a child?
Oh, we excelled in school.
I liked school. I always did.
My sisters and brothers, I really, I don't know that they liked school as much as I did.
But we went because my mom, you see, thought it was important for us to go to school.
And because we worked on a farm, we weren't always allowed to go every day.
Sometimes the crops would just need to be taken in.
We just needed to save the crops.
But mom would work so very, very hard to do all of it,
to make up for our not being in the field.
She would get up in the morning and go to the field with my dad,
and she would work, oh, she would work so hard.
She'd pick cotton.
What a terrible thing to do to pick cotton.
But she would pick cotton.
She would pick cotton.
She would pick cotton to make up for the fact that we weren't there.
And then we were told to come from school directly from school and change our clothes really, really quickly
and run, run, run to the field because mom would be there working so hard.
And then when we got to the field to help pick the cotton,
we would go to the house to make us something good to eat for supper.
She always did good supper for us.
But I had a good life.
I didn't know I was a poor girl.
I didn't think about that too much.
How closely connected was the black community in the area of Wise, North Carolina?
Because of course, farmland sketch can be, depending on population, that's fairly spread out.
Well, there were.
But you see, we had the church and we had the school.
They were centers for the activity of the community.
And we took advantage of those.
My parents would come to school for Easter programs.
They would come for programs that we had in the evenings where their children performed.
And they saw their children.
And my parents were very much, as were the parents of other members in the community,
very much involved with the school.
Not like now.
Not so much so.
Is that the case now?
As I think about it, as I go home to see.
But when I grew up, parents were very much involved in the school of.
Very much.
Did you remember the call?
Sometimes we did and sometimes we didn't.
I think the times when we didn't was when my brothers were away.
And we didn't have a brother to drive.
My dad didn't ever drive.
He never, ever drove.
And I don't know why that was.
But he just never drove a car.
He never was licensed.
But when my brothers were there, before they would go off to the army or go somewhere,
we would have a car.
I just suggested something.
I was interested.
I know there are 11 siblings ahead of you.
But in broad, one very important part about your life history course is here.
You're the first in your family to go to a four-year college.
Yes.
And what were the life paths taken by a soldier older siblings?
Oh.
We didn't have money to go to college.
I like to talk about this part of the literature.
And I'm not very much willing and coming forth coming to talking about my family very much.
But I always want to say that I always thought how ironic.
I thought always that I was not the smartest of my siblings.
I was just the luckiest one in this regard.
There was never money.
There weren't many scholarships, you know, then as there are now for black kids to go off to school.
So my brothers and sisters will go up and they went off.
We had a thriving, much more thriving than now, manufacturing country then.
Manufacturing was big and so they got job in factories.
One of my brothers worked, two of my brothers worked at Ford Motors.
One of them, you know, my brother, I had a brother who would always,
well, he would never drive any car.
There wasn't a general motor's car and he would always say,
why didn't you get a general motor's car?
There were loyal to the factories that they worked in and some of them worked.
I had a brother who worked in a shipyard in Newport News, Virginia for a very long time.
For a long time then, I made a good living.
I had another brother who worked in the school system of New York.
I think he might have been a janitor.
They call him something else now, engineers of some kind of another.
I think he was probably just a janitor, but he took pride in his job.
Then they all were proud that they were never fired from anything.
They all bought their homes and took care of their wives in that way.
How did it come to pass that your family was able to send you to Bennett?
Well, farmers got social security. It's as simple as that.
My sense of these things sometimes, and I think about them,
is that it's so connected and so unknown by people who sit in decision-making,
positions in the world. They don't quite know how one thing affects another.
When did the farmers get social security in 1957?
Until that time, farmers did not get social security.
When farmers got social security, the recipients of social security were able to get it retrograde.
They were able to get it retroactive to the time that they turned 65.
I remember going home and working so hard, helping my parents.
Not just my parents, but helping the people in the neighborhood go and sign up to prove their ages.
I learned so much about the Bible, where names were recorded.
I remember the people in my community had been born at home with midwives.
The midwife would have four babies delivered in a week,
and she'd have to go all the way into town to register them.
She said, I'll turn them all in when I get a lot.
There's all kinds of stories that I loved hearing about my folk who that person was not really born on that day.
That person was born on another day. That's how that goes.
We had good times talking about how the midwife misnamed somebody or forgot,
spelled the name incorrectly. They're those stories.
Everybody knew everybody in my neighborhood.
We got together and I learned my first chance to figure out how to convince somebody about your age.
If you don't have it in the courthouse, if you don't have a birth certificate,
it's that you go to the family Bible because most people entered the deaths and births.
If you have to go looking for a history of the people, find deaths in birth, find a Bible,
or some of the religious places in the Bible, and the black community was the Bible.
Then they could tell you what year a flood came,
or when a tornado came and killed three kids,
or these catastrophic in nature, these catastrophic things in nature,
would be landmarks that would help prove their age.
I helped some people prove that they were at least 65.
It's to establish when they turn 65 so that they could get their checks
and begin to get social security.
Then my mom said, when my dad got a check, my mom said,
this one will go to college.
This one actually had no choice to go to college when I think about it.
I think I might not have some that.
I would have so disappointed her and that would have killed me, I think.
She's so much, and then, only then, did I know that she had wanted every single one of those kids to go to school.
So she engaged with us in the evenings when we did our lessons.
Lessons were very important for us to do, and she used to spell with us.
One was a terrific speller. She would spell with us, but our names had spell.
They spell anything we'd see have contests.
We spent a lot of time together as a family.
And that's...
I'm interested to get a sense as best you can recall this and think about how other persons might have given a description.
But what do you like?
I like to see you're all thinking about heading up to college.
But who, you have a set of well-flung-related ambitions at that time?
Or did you know what you wanted to study?
No, I was going to teach.
Something is general.
I don't...
I really don't recall.
I think you would have to ask someone else when I was here.
It's what I don't think I was.
I don't think I was as independent of my family as I might have been.
I think I was always maybe too late thinking, you know, independent of what my mother needed, what my father needed,
and how we would work together.
You see, growing up, we all talked about how we're going to all work and we're going to own the land.
So it was always a we that when we talked about the things we were going to do,
always at the center of it was we were going to get the land and dad's going to finish paying for the land
and then we're going to get a car and then we're going to get a big house and then we're going to get...
And so we...
We was the propellant there.
It propelled me in my thinking.
And I think maybe in 17, I didn't think so much about going off to do anything.
I knew I was going to teach, I think.
I was going to...
Who else was I going to teach?
And why is, of course.
Let's take this a little quick pause.
We're rolling.
We're back on after a short break.
Dr. Terry, I have just one quick question before we turn towards screens for our independent college.
Did you happen to know what I'm not thinking the answer would be?
Did you happen to know Theaoseus Tobias Clayton Sr and Warren?
Yes.
What you did?
I knew him.
No, so I knew him.
I met him, I think, when I was in college.
I think he came to Warren to an Asaloyah and immediately he and his wife Eva became members of our community.
I knew them.
I know them.
He would be...
Well, I was going to just a minute if I was ready.
We're back on after a break to tell them.
Dr. Terry, I know...
I think I know that your parents drove you to the college here and moved you in and followed 57 years ago.
Yes, they did.
What did you discover here in thriving and Hispanic college?
It was a big day for me.
For the whole community.
I came from someplace.
I just didn't...
So I came being supported by the whole community.
They prayed for me at church.
They gave me a few pennies here and there.
As I said, we didn't have a lot of money.
I had a little scholarship.
SAT.
I had done well enough to have a little scholarship and I was going to work a little bit.
But there was always that.
Let me give you a few pennies.
I came being born up by the good wishes of the community.
And off we came to Bennett College.
I'd never been to Bennett College before.
I'd never been to Greensboro before.
And I arrived here to have ourselves, you know, just sort of swallowed up my parents and me and all of us.
But a lot of parents and a lot of students all being deposited by our parents.
And it was an only feeling when they said goodbye and left.
It was very lonely.
Who got some of the people who would, you know, in short order become persons who were important to you here on the campus faculty staff?
That was me.
I met when I, as my parents were getting me situated in my room, there was a woman who was bringing her daughter.
There was a girl, Roslyn Smith, being deposited from West Virginia and her mom met my mom and they talked.
And Roslyn's mother told my mom how they talked and just told each other so much and so little time I never know.
But here's what got established in that little while.
Roslyn's mother had other children in college at the same time.
And so she immediately knew she told Roslyn immediately she wouldn't be coming home.
Roslyn's mom wouldn't be coming home.
There wasn't going to be money to bring Roslyn home except at Christmas time and in the summertime.
My mom told Mrs. Smith that we lived a couple of hours up the road and they would be driving back to see me often and I could come home quite often.
I could come home for Thanksgiving.
I could come home whenever.
And that Roslyn could come home with me anytime.
So Mrs. Smith and Mrs. Alexander sort of bonded that day and they exchanged children.
My mom became surrogate, Roslyn's mom and Roslyn's mom became sort of my mom.
Although it would take a long time before I got to West Virginia to meet Roslyn's mother.
Roslyn went home with me that very, very first break that we had and she went home with me for all four years.
My very best friend to this day is Roslyn Smith.
She is actually living in Greensboro.
And so she retired here some 10 years ago from New York where she had been working in social works.
She came back when she retired to Greensboro after she left her.
She said why did you come back to Greensboro?
I mean, did Bennett have anything to do with it?
But she came to Greensboro and then of course when I took the job here I was delighted that she's here.
So we are where we met.
She was, as I think I understand, she was really kind of in a different part of campus in the classroom.
So to speak.
She studied sociology and political science.
I was doing English in theater.
Tell me about the world of being an English student and a theater student at those late 50s.
Oh my goodness.
It was wonderful.
My English professor was Hobart Jarrett.
Well, I had several, but Dr. Jarrett was the man who taught me literature.
Dr. Jarrett, what a wonderful man, what a brilliant man.
All of my faculty were.
Dr. Jarrett was hard.
He was tough.
He ex-exacted absolute perfection.
And we were arrogant enough to think we could give it to him.
You know, he really had us just chombed into thinking that we could write anything we could articulate in it.
We could debate anybody.
He was just a wonderful teacher and he empowered us a big deal, but no nonsense.
So I was very much engaged with him.
He would walk on campus and say, Miss Alexander, I am going to pick up a ball.
What am I?
That's a book and I'd say literary history of England.
He'd say yes.
I mean, those little games, you know, he would, he would set the show off about how area that he was.
And we reveled in it.
He also was a very handsome man.
And he smoked a pipe and he was so elegant.
We all, we all just sort of drooled after Dr. Jarrett, but in a nice way.
We were so, so proud to say we were his students.
Now that was Dr. Jarrett.
Then there was Dr. Crawford who taught us grammar.
He was less, how should I say this?
He didn't, he was, I don't want to say he was less polished, but he was less polished.
That's the fact.
He was less polished.
But he was a terror.
He didn't like you to spit verbs or anything of that sort.
So he taught us grammar and he would have us at this sentence.
He would make us post verbs and he would make us diagram sentences.
He was, he was tough.
I wasn't, I don't think I was one of his favorite students.
But I was, I was treated kindly by him because I could diagram a sentence, you know, and I got out of his way.
But there, he was, he was serious and you know, you know,
he was, he was, he was just a serious man.
And so he wasn't quite like, like Dr., Dr. Hobai Jarrett.
Then we had, in the theater, we had Fred Eady, who had come to us from Howard.
I was a terrific director.
And we got him married.
We thought he needed to be married.
We, we selected the lady on the campus that we thought he ought to be married to.
And so we bought her, we collected money and bought her flowers and sent her flowers and said they were from Mr. Edy.
But we told him, we told him, we said now we, we took this lady these flowers.
You should follow up and we put your name on it.
He did and you want to know something really funny.
They got married.
We always took credit for that.
And they were, they were, they were, they were, they were, they were beautiful.
What can I say?
I lived in Honors Dorm, which was, can't talk.
We were very proud to be Bennett girls.
Because we were taught every day that we were as good as anybody in the world,
and better than a lot of people in the world, and had responsibility to help those who were as fortunate as we were.
That there was something in life that required us to be as good as we could be,
and to give back to the communities from which we can.
It was that sense that led us to be cognizant of what was happening in the community,
of helping people to get registered, of both understanding the importance of registering to vote,
and getting people to do that, taking ourselves into the community to be helpful,
to help people in, in the ways that we could, because of food drives.
The whole sense and to talk about the community, you know, I grew up.
That's very important, but I'm saying, not to use so much as I've reflect on it,
why I think it was important to me that they taught us these things,
is because you see, I talk about having been happy when I was growing up as a youngster.
What I mean is that I felt safe, that happiness was somehow connected with being safe,
but I can remind you that in that time, the whole southern terrain was dotted with white-only signs,
with the signs that said, you know, colors, or negro signs, sort of,
that sort of, there were reminders that there were places that you couldn't go,
and the places that you ought not to go if you wanted to be safe.
Safety was a part of being happy, and that's, and when you were cocooned in safety,
and you were just such a, and that's what this campus was, this campus was a place
that we knew that we were taken care of, and now we were asked to give,
all we could give in the classes, but we also knew that we were special.
And that is why it was inevitable that we entered into the city.
We knew they were wrong.
You see, you can't have someone inside the gates being taught how they could be the best everybody,
and anybody, they could be everything, and then walk right out the gate and be told,
you can't sit here.
And I think it's very important to know that F.W. Woolworth became,
and I do, that you can't sit down for a coke.
Now, you know, you could go into F.W. Woolworth.
F.W. Woolworth was not, was not closed to black patronage at all.
You could go into F.W. Woolworth, you could buy anything you wanted, that they sold in F.W. Woolworth that month.
You just couldn't sit down to get saved, which is the lunch counter.
So it was the lunch counter. You couldn't sit down there to eat.
So you see, that stood in stark contrast to all the things that we had going on here at Bennett,
where we dressed for dinner in the evenings and sat with tablecloths,
and we learned which fork to use, and how, and we went downtown where it hats,
and we wore gloves, and we were Bennett College student activists.
You can see how it wouldn't, it was just such a jarring thing to be told,
well, Bennett lady, guess what, you can't sit down there and have a cherry coke.
So those, that, that, they, there were things that got us,
there was a diseased as it were, there was a dis, dis, dis, eat,
it's uncomfortable, one cannot square those two things.
Did you, through these, through your first couple years of college,
I mean, you, you've been a college student, is, is, is a very encompassing and engaging kind of experience
when you're happy and thriving in your classes and all.
What, what portion of your attention is some broad kind of sense?
Did you give to these wider questions?
I mean, Little Rock is happening the, the first desegregation of the local Greensboro schools is happening.
Yes.
There are some early law suits and moving through the courts filed by people like Dr. Simkin's to try to break down
barriers of segregation in the city.
Yes.
How much of that was, was a part of your, you know, what, what you gave your attention to because there were lots of other things that were keeping on.
That's your work.
But, but I, I told you a part of Bennett was always that the education that Bennett was to prepare you to, to make a contribution to the world
and to be reconnected into your community.
My classmates had experiences before we got here.
We didn't, even I didn't come here, you know, sort of from Mars where everything was great and we never had a sense that there was, that could be clashes between white and black.
We all, we all knew about those things.
I, you know, I grew up here and been knowing about such things, you know, my brothers were, my mother were at all the time about what would happen.
So, what I mean when I say we were safe is exactly that.
A storm is going on around us.
We are aware of the storm, but we can also feel safe in here.
And that's when I meant when I said that safety was a very important part of how I, I think, became, was a healthy,
was a healthy person because I look back over it, I think I was healthy.
I think, I think I mean a healthy ego, a healthy psyche going up in that.
I don't think it damaged me in any way.
Now I might be wrong, but I don't, I don't think I grew up with my, my mother was Wise, North Carolina and she would talk about these things to us precisely so that they wouldn't scare us so much.
Or they would, we would know how to live with them.
My mother would tell us, she didn't want us to hate white people.
Now mother, my mother had this room. She wouldn't let us say they when we talked about white people.
She wouldn't let us say they did so.
So, one day she took a piece of chalk and she wrote T, H, E, Y, and then she erased the T on the one hand and she erased the Y and she said,
you come and tell me what he did.
You named him and you named her and we will deal with that, but you will not ever speak of all white people as bad or haven't you,
you're bad and you see we had, we understood that.
So, we couldn't afford to be shielded from what was happening in the world.
I just am always grateful that my parents taught us, I think, the best way to negotiate it.
And she told my son, as I said, I have one son, and he's always so pleased to remind me that when he was home talking to his grandma,
he told her something about some white people doing something.
Grandma, why did you let them do that?
Why do you let them call you Mary and you come?
She says, Mike, you know, they're as good as they know how to be.
What are you going to do with that?
They're as good as they know how to be.
And so, there was a way that she, my mother allowed us to have an ego about who we were and she wouldn't let anybody damage that.
So, we were just told.
They're, they're about, she said to Mike, they're as good as they know how to be.
What were you going to do with that?
Then, they're as good as they know how to be.
But to come back to your question, so here, yes, we had Dr. Edmunds, we had Roslyn and my friend was in sociology.
They didn't talk about, I mean, we had a life out there.
They talked about issues.
We talked in our classes about what was happening in the world.
We didn't pretend that the world wasn't out there.
I think you missed Dr. King's appearance on the campus in 58, is that correct?
Yes.
By 59, especially Fall of 59, of course, the momentum is gathering and we'll, we'll soon lead to some direct action protests.
What do you think about the Fall of 59 and some of the women here on the campus, of course, were talking very actively, as you've just been saying, and really thinking very hard about this question?
Well, it's really started in the, in the, my classmates who were in sociology classes, they were with sociology, Roslyn, Smith, Gwen, Gwen Mackel, Shirley, Dismute, that group, Gloria Brown.
They were the ones that were engaged, engaged in, in an intense way.
But you see, they would come back to the dorms and tell us what was happening.
And as I say, Roslyn was my best friend.
We knew what was going on.
We knew, and you start as a theoretical, how do we conduct ourselves in the world, if that is the case?
And then someone says, why don't, what would happen if we boycott it?
What would happen if that, how can these barriers be torn down?
These were questions over being asked. You know, there had been sittings before.
Greensboro.
There had been protests before. There had been marches before.
Bennett College student activists and the showing of the film, The Birth of a Nation, which is a pretty ugly film.
You've done voter registration for the rest of the day.
In its stories, we had done voter registration.
So I cannot tell you exactly and precisely what moment, you know, that was this great epiphany and we did things.
But what I end up knowing was that students were planning and talking about a boycott.
Going downtown and picketing.
What would happen if they picketed, what would happen, and then it went from picketing to, well, what would happen if we sat down at the lunch counter.
So these were conversations that were being talked about students, which talked about nonviolence.
That's exactly what, that's a route that people don't talk of, remember, that these students were, we were, Dr. Edmunds and our faculty talked about nonviolence?
You remember King was talking about non-violence, all of a sudden, nonviolence?
If somebody hits you, you hit them back, you know, if it's supposed to be associated with that.
How do you conduct yourself? Is it dangerous, you know, what happened?
So it was in the air and we were here on the campus and yes, we talked about those things.
Do you think that these, you described the name to group of women who were very much active in these kinds of conversations on the campus and friends of yours?
Do you think that among those women there is a sense that they were, well, I don't know if I'm going to answer this way.
To what extent would they think they ought to be placed in the, how much should they be credited for the full realization that impulse here in the community among students and now we're reaching over across to North Carolina A&T State University, that opened the door to direct action process?
Are they credited sufficiently, I guess, as well?
They would say not.
Back in two years ago, I, for the 50th anniversary of the Greensboro sit-ins, I was here and as a new provost and I remembered those days.
So I called a group of them to come back to talk about that and so we had a retrospective when Gwen Mackel came, Shirley disney came, Dolores Finger came, Roslyn Smith came, Linda Brown was here.
We had, we talked, we were in the chapel and we talked about that and they would say no.
Here's how they talk about it.
They say that they indeed did not argue with the fact that the four young men at North Carolina A&T State University were the first to sit down.
But they say that it was not spontaneous, that it had come, that action had been born of a plan, that had been carefully, carefully considered and deliberated beginning here on Bennett's campus with the girls.
And that they had in fact been happily considering it and Dr. Jarrett said to them, well, you girls shouldn't get engaged in doing that alone because, you know, this is the girls must be protected.
So they were encouraged to invite the North Carolina A&T State University boys to sit with them and to plan this, just sit in and what it would be because you see we're talking about something that could be very dangerous.
Nobody asked their parents, our parents did not send us down here to go do that, you hear me? And they would not have been happy maybe. Some of them might have.
My classmates have wonderful stories about their lives.
Green Mackels parents had been run out of Mississippi because of her dad's political action. These young women weren't babes in the woods.
My own father had had his problems.
We had early dissimuse and she just couldn't figure out, nobody had ever asked her to sit in the back of a bus or anything.
So we all came with a real deep feeling that that's wrong. That's wrong and we knew that.
So they wanted to correct it and to be educated and not do anything about it was not the education wasn't going to mean very much.
So these girls would tell you that they worked very hard, they discussed everything and they can tell you that Dr. Willa B. Player, our president was involved as well.
Dr. Willa B. Player was told and Dr. Willa B. Player said she couldn't tell us not to her girls. We were always called her girls. She couldn't tell her girls not to engage in that.
But she did point out that it would be kind of folly to start the Greensboro sit-ins, to start the action before the Christmas vacation.
And so if you started it, it Thanksgiving, say for instance, and then everybody would say sorry, I've been politically active but I've got to go home now and I'll come back. I'll see you after the vacation.
So she said she cautioned them to wait and they did.
And then it told a lot of us when they came back that they were all ready to start and they came back and on February 1st was it?
The young men sat down. Now here's an important thing I asked when, Gwen Mackel, when, where were you on that day?
When they sat down she said I was in Woolworths.
Why were you there? She said because we were there.
But first you had to go buy something. You said we knew how to do it. You had to go because we had been trained that if you didn't buy something you could be tossed out of the store.
So you go in and store you buy something. And she says I was standing and waiting because it was a plan.
And it did not, it was a plan that had been created here on the campus and so the girls would think that they did not get enough credit. That's what they would think.
Very quickly many other students take places at the lunch counter and there are carpools and careful assignment of rotating shifts of students and all in.
And you sat down there too.
Yes I do. Besides Linda Brown.
I think we might have been young because honestly I felt proud.
I don't think my mother ever felt, maybe she felt proud but I think that was not her main feeling. I think she was terrified.
I know that now because I have a child and I mean I have a son who's not a child anymore. He's a very big role man but even so I think as a mother I would be afraid but I'm going to tell you we were proud.
I was very proud. I would tell you something else.
I never ever understood the hatred that came. It was absolutely surprising because I did not understand what people would glare at us with such hatred.
That was a little unnerving but I was basically very proud to have done that.
Did you are unloading about it? Did your parents have any words of guidance for you or come on tour?
It was interesting enough my parents, my mother never talked to me about that very much. She was very quiet. My mom was never very quiet but my mom didn't talk about that very much.
I think I understand why. I think my mom didn't want to say I wish you hadn't done it. I think my mom regretted the world as it was that it had to be done but I don't think my mom was related to that.
I think my mom would have forgiven me if I had called in sick. I think she might have. I don't think she would have been too upset if I had called in sick but she never ever let me know from her own words what she felt.
She was just quiet.
It was interesting if you would maybe just say a few words about her because as you've already said she made clear in certain unmistakable ways.
Let me back on after short break. I want to ask a little bit for your thoughts and perspective on Dr. Willa B. Player in Perl here at Bennett College.
I think I'm going to talk about the leadership at North Carolina A&T State University because of course the institutions have separate histories, many similar general crowd aspects of the history but also different relations to the state of North Carolina etc.
To talk a little bit about the education leadership in that era and the forces active upon that leadership.
Dr. Willa B. Player was, let me first tell you a little bit about Dr. Willa B. Player. She was a big, big, big woman and I don't mean in statue, I mean in physical statue.
In the shadow she cast over the campus when she walked and she was quiet. She was a very, very, very dignified woman.
But we all believe, not I, we all believe that she was profoundly committed to making Bennett women.
The girls who came to Bennett and to women who could stand in the world strong women with a commitment to social justice.
Now that, I don't mean just to being good English teachers, being good, you know, math teachers, being good physicists.
I mean undergirding all of that with a profound sense of social justice.
And that was her, I mean and she, she talked about that but quietly in her philosophy she talked about the fact that education was no good if you didn't use it to correct wrongs in society.
She just believed that and so she didn't make fiery speeches about that. She wasn't a fiery speech in person but she was very quietly committed and you knew when you were in her presence that it was not just nonsense that she was talking.
She really believed and lived what she talked about. So I play it was a really, really brave woman and if she cared about anybody, she cared about what the legacy that she would pass on.
She would pass on to us at Bennett College. She was an incredible woman so that's got to play her.
I don't know very much about the leadership at North Carolina A&T State University but I do know that whatever is said and written about the movement here as it played itself out in Greensboro,
Bennett College women were involved in it from the top down and we were supported and we were encouraged and so the college was there.
It was what we learned as the college is what we were brought together to do as the college.
Now I don't know what, and Dr. Willa B. Player and we knew she was looking over us. We knew she was monitoring us.
We knew for instance, we knew she said that we could go down and march and sit down and sit at the lunch counter but we would have to turn in our grades.
There was no faculty member was to give us excuses. When I was in Amherst, the kids used to ask when they went off to march on a protest or something they'd come and asked the professors to overlook the fact that they were in the office.
They were there to forgive their bad reasons and you don't do that. That's not a political stance.
You're not giving up anything. If you're not willing to risk your grades or to walk out and take a D to go do something and you don't mean it very much.
So here we knew that this was something real, it was profound and it was sort of like, it was like Dr. Willa B. Player was here with us all the way and we knew with that.
And anybody who saw us knew that we came from there, they could trace us all the way back to where Bennett started and that was what I could say about Dr. Willa B. Player.
I don't know very much about who was, I don't even know who the name of the president that they and T was.
I can suspect that he didn't spend a lot of time, that his young people down there for me and T was spending a lot of time being supported and encouraged by the president.
I don't know but I said that but I can believe to my heart that he probably wanted the Greensboro sit-ins to be successful.
I can believe in my heart that he wanted those Greensboro sit-ins to be very successful and whether or not he was able to say, I don't know, but at there as you say, there are different relationships that people had with the state and with being funded by the state.
But Dr. Willa B. Player, you see, we were private. We were private and if you ask, every one of us would tell you, I think if we hadn't been private, I do believe Dr. Willa B. Player would have done exactly what she did.
I cannot prove that but I believe that because it was so much a part of her.
Later, you must know this story that when the girls were arrested during the second wave, they were put in jail.
She got in her car and drove down. Now she didn't get a driver to take her downtown.
She got in her car alone and drove downtown to go and to say, these are my girls, I brought them there, homework. I want to see after them. I want to see what they were doing.
I believe she would have taken risk. Risk that others did not and would not have taken.
I don't think that she would have judged them for that. I believe Dr. Willa B. Player would not have become the enemy of anybody at any one of these institutions because they did what they did.
I think she would simply say, you must understand. I do what I have to do and that's the difference between us. I think that's the difference in how I would say Dr. Willa B. Player.
I don't think you actually said the word. She went to the jail to see the men that were arrested.
That's a very dangerous, black woman in a car. A lot of people in Greensboro did not like what was happening and to see this woman.
There had been a crossburn. She did have a crossburned at the college president's house. Dr. Willa B. Player was a committed and a sincere soldier. She really was.
Let me turn your attention to graduation and beyond because of course that spring then. spring of '61 graduation.
I'm very interested to have you describe your ambition and your experience in UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill.
I think I have a lot of things to ask about that. Let me invite you to begin that story.
At that time I didn't know so much when I came to Bennett as a freshman about what I wanted to do. I wanted to teach. I went back home and teach and Wise, North Carolina.
By the time I had studied with Dr. Jarrett and Dr. Crawford, I wanted to do really, really I wanted to work in the middle. I wanted to be an English teacher. I wanted to study English.
I knew that I needed to go to graduate school. At least I had been encouraged by Dr. Jarrett to go to graduate school. Dr. Crawford and Dr. Elizabeth Soel who came later. She thought I wrote well and that always pleased me. She said go to. She was an English woman.
She was a late-to-been and I think she worked at UNC Greensboro. Until that time I never could figure out how this worked.
If one wanted to go to graduate school prior to that, prior to my time was coming and it was just changing when I entered UNC Greensboro just beginning to change. If one were black you could apply to the state.
After you had been accepted at a Northern University, on the state of course would pay your way. Now of course we...
So as to avoid the obligation to desegregate and to have you in the classes there. So we know that history. James Meredith, Ole Miss and all of that.
My father and mother said to me, if you want to go to graduate school, I'm a taxpayer. My dad said go to chapel.
So and this was my mom really pushed this idea. Go to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. Now this is after the Greensboro sit-ins you see and all of that. So now it's go to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. I think my mom thought all right she can do it. She's okay.
So mom was a little less tense. Well I should never talk to me about Bennett and Greensboro sit-ins. She did say she wanted me to go to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. And she said, because you'll be nearer home and I didn't believe that. I thought she was kind of proud that I would go to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. So I did. I went to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill.
There's a funny story about UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. I left here and I went to Hartford, Connecticut where I lived with my sister and brother-in-law. And I worked as a waitress there. But my sister took all of my money. She took all of my money every week. She'd take my money.
And then when I came back, God read it to come back to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. She gave me my money. That was enforced savings. And she took my shop and all of my sisters and brothers were always very kind to me.
Well, I came home and then before I got home, I had called to UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill to ask to apply for graduate housing. And I was going to stay in the dorm. And yes, and they asked, did I fill out the form? They mailed it to me. To Hartford, I mailed it back. And yes, I would like a roommate.
And so they sent me my room assignment and said, I should appear. It's a certain place on a certain day to pick up the key. And I sent forward my deposit, et cetera.
So on that day, my dad took me and my mom and my brother. We drove down. My sister, we drove down and I went to the place. And I said, I'm Mr. Alexander. I'm here to get my key. And there was a look of absolute,
a consternation on the woman's face. And she finally said, you can't be Esther Alexander. Well, and that kind of confused me on my dad. Because, you know, yes, I am. Mr. Alexander, as it turned out, you know what she had done. She had not known that I was black. And she had paired me with a white roommate.
And there was a ruling at UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill at that time that that was not to be. So she didn't quite know what to do with me.
Now, I thought, oh boy, this is not the best way to enter school. But I learned something that day. And my mom, and I talked about it a lot.
They kept me inside. And eventually, they came and said, now you have your room. Your room is ready. And I said to my mom, as we went down here, I said, well, I'm going to be the only person in that room.
She said, yes, I expect so. But, and I would have, I was prepared to just be furious. I think I was. But on the way there, there were white girls sitting on suitcases because they didn't have very much spaced housing space for a graduate student. And they would have to go into city someplace.
Those girls were from I don't know where. But they were saying to me, do you have a roommate? Do you want me to come back? Do you want to like a roommate? Would you like a roommate? I'd be happy to have a room with you.
And the less than I learned, and my mom and I talked about it when we got in our room, she said, this is not the girls. And you have to remember that this is my mother saying, there is good as they know how to be.
My mother said, it's not the girls. It's the law. It's the ruling. It's the ruling that you hate. Don't hate the girls. She was right. I met some good friends there. They were never like Ross and Smith because they could come to a certain point in friendship.
And there were doorways they couldn't cross or wouldn't let themselves cross. And I probably wouldn't let mine cross either. But they didn't do me harm. And they didn't wish me harm.
And I managed to get a master's degree at UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill without much fanfare.
The faculty and the academic experience. So, I took a class with C. C. Hugh Holman.
Remember C. C. Hugh Holman? Brawl Hibbert Holman's handbook to English literature. I was fortunate to have a class with him. He was a brilliant man, a charming man, and a gentleman.
My faculty members there were gentlemen. And I didn't have a woman. It's not interesting. I just thought about that.
I didn't have that was not one course that I took there. But I was only there to get the master's. I'm just going to tell you I didn't want to stay for it.
I had to go to work. I had to go to the master's. I'd been in school too long. I needed to take off. I couldn't stay and go straight through. I needed to have a break. So I did.
And then I went to St. Custon College and taught for a couple of years. I really did. If I was going to do this work, I really did need to get the doctorate.
And so I went off to and ended up getting the doctorate at UMass Amherst.
Let's take just a little break.
Okay, Dr. Terry, we're back on after a short break and kind of our last segment here. I want to ask about some of your experiences up in Amherst specifically around.
And there's so much we have limited time. So I'll skip past other things that would readily merit a whole separate interview. And forgive me for that.
I want to ask about 69 the creation of African American Studies program at UMass Amherst Amherst. And you would of course direct that program for a couple of decades.
Yeah, but not at the beginning. Not be right. You got to be at she 74. So later you would step into that role.
But that was I think one of two programs at the time that was created. It's kind of a capstone to your ten years program and former chair.
You'd be one of the very first two. I think in the first two in the nation to offer a PhD African American. So broad theme.
But I'm interested in kind of both the creation of the foundation period and how you thought about the pedagogical challenge, the frameworks, the narratives, the broad theme.
Well, where do you want me to start? Massachusetts was. There was easy in Massachusetts. I think what happened in Massachusetts could not have happened at other places. And I'll tell you why.
We had a very, very, very sympathetic administration on the campus.
There were some things that had happened at and in the in the college community of faculty and friends. It was an incredible assembly of people there.
First of all, in 1959, the Massachusetts had the UMass Amherst press had come forward with the Massachusetts review. That's the college littleware magazine.
Read the pages of that magazine and it's almost it's it's eerie because when that magazine was launched, it was dedicated to the four young men who watched it.
It referenced the four young men who had sat down at North Carolina's North Carolina A&T State University University in the 19th, the 19th.
It committed itself to have been a magazine. The pages of which would be readily available to black writers, to young black writers in the in the country as they expressed themselves and their traditions. It was an amazing thing.
I did not know that. I had no way of knowing that. But the group of people who had started the Massachusetts review would become my family almost when I got to UMass Amherst.
When I got to UMass Amherst, there were very few black people on that campus. That didn't bother me by now.
I was there to study to get the doctorate. I was an older woman now. I'm all of 22. I'm all of 22. I'm a grown woman now.
Actually, I was really 25. When I got there, but I was able now, I think I'm certainly grown. I'm able to handle this time.
I got there. At the same time, I got there. Michael Thelwell came. Then Bernard W. Bell was there. My husband to be Eugene Terry was there.
We were black people now. Let me tell you that we were 50% of all black people on the campus at that time.
How do we get there? We got there because Sterling A. Brown out of Howard University had been sending his graduate students.
We were writing to him saying we want to go study at Howard University. He said, no, no, no, no, no. You don't want to study with me.
You need to study. You really want to study literature. You really want to put American literature. You need to go study with Sidney Kaplan, who knows more about black American literature and how it fits than in American literature than anybody I know.
He had sent us all there. Sterling had sent us all there. We used to say we were Sterling's old gang and folk there. Sidney Kaplan, of course, was a graduate program there.
As soon as he got to be the head of the graduate program in the English department, he's a graduate program director. He's the one who's going to select students. He had written to Sterling and said, send me students. Sydney had been a part of creating the Massachusetts review.
Now he's a graduate program director in the English department. So he says send me some students. And we all got there to be students. And the first thing we started to be involved in, of course, was a program, not a department, a program under the ages of the English department.
We started the match. You know, we started and we had we would go visit the homes in the evenings of the professors and the staff people who ran the Massachusetts review. It was a wonderful, wonderful place to be at that time because politics was everything.
We talked about the world. We talked about making it better. We talked about obligation to make it better. Michael Thelwell had come from the movement. He had been involved in getting the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party up in Atlantic City with Julian Julian Bond.
It was just the most amazing, amazing assembly of people. And then we talked about what would a program look like that would infuse. And here is what we always talked about.
We never talked about erasing American literature. We talked about embellishing it with the story of the African American in that contribution.
So ours was an American story. And we wanted that ours would have to fulfill what was the narrative of the Black person would be a narrative that belonged in the consideration of narratives for the American literature, what was uniquely American.
We always talked about that. And then we had a program. And then the next thing we knew we were talking about it. We were talking about a department. And so we went.
Amherst (UMass Amherst) is the flagship, but the president's office was in Boston. So when we went to talk about when my colleagues went to talk about the establishment of such a thing to the president and to the board of trustees, we were never alone.
We never were not one thing happened at UMass Amherst of protests. Even when the kids were protesting or whatever, there was never one such action that had all Black kids and only Black kids, some only Black faculty involved.
So we had a wonderful assemblage of people who were there to work with us and to stand by us and to help us with that. And so it was easy. So I'd love to tell people that if you know what was happening at Cornell, what was happening all over the place where fights were breaking out and there were others.
Today that we were granted the rights to establish our independent department. And after American studies, people kind of yond and voted it and went on and nobody, nothing was blown up. It was a real quiet thing. And I felt kind of, you know, I thought, we're, let down. We wanted there to be some protests. Well, it's not protest.
Let there be some celebratory noise of some kind, but it was like, it's okay. It's all right. I think UMass Amherst was a very special place for me. I spent a long time there in my career, grew a lot there and got to learn so much more than I ever learned because, because we're there with thresholds that I thought I couldn't.
And other people thought I couldn't pass at say a UNC-Chapel Hill-Chapel Hill. I was pulled across those in many ways, and UMass Amherst. And so it was, it was a really, if I look back at what I, what I had done in terms of how it just worked right to be the end, it just worked absolutely right. And I was able to join with people black and white to make sure that we had a program that's a good program.
That's a program that talks about making what was existent in the out of the tower better because it would be, it would, it would not now have to close off classes. We opened doors and we knew that we had students who could do that. We knew that we had a country that needed to understand that and who could swallow that and grow from it.
That's what we thought. That's what we did and we have a great program at UMass Amherst and I was very, very sad to leave it, but I needed to.
Just the final question. There is a nice kind of closing of a circle when you come back as provost here.
Yeah, that's from back as provost.
2009, and just interested in maybe a final thought or a reflection on Bennett today and how it stands in the lives of the young women who are here now and in the community.
It's a small, everything has changed because it's, when I was here, the signs were up. Blacks, this way, whites this way, don't come in.
You know, to knock down the signs sometimes lose us not knowing what we have to do and if we're not very careful, we can, we can to think we're free.
And there are no more things to be done. There are no movements to have. But there are now. There are, there are economic considerations.
And I say to the young women who come to me, who want to know, Dr., what you do when we sit down, did you sit down? I say, well, you know, you only can run the relay.
You run the lap you're in. And then you pass it on. But when you pass it, that person doesn't, doesn't get to run the lap that you ran. That lap's been run.
You have to run another lap. You have to run your lap. So I say to the students here that the world now is different. It's not the same as it was.
But it also is not perfect yet because it's a far away, the Greensboro even, far away from being perfect. Doesn't have some of the problems that it had, but it has other ones. And they've got to find them.
Here's what I say to students that you still have the obligation and the responsibility to make social justice and equality apart,
a partner with you as you develop whatever skills you want to develop and you pursue whatever course of study you want to pursue.
You have got to be the best. You have got to give you all and you've got to have a part of it committed to giving back to the community.
I think that. I think that. So I think now I think I go through here and young people got Twitter and technology. But I can't stand Twitter.
I, you know, it's so limited. I don't do Twitter. And I try very hard to stay away from blogging and all of that. But you know, the students have to do that.
And I have to know enough about it to get through. Their world has got to put all of this novel change.
It's also ingested in many ways and unequal in many ways. And if they're not careful, they won't see it.
So they've got to work really hard to do that. And I think then it is a good place to be. I think Bennett can become a haven for at least 900 little girls to make a minute.
To make them into big women. That's what I work to do. And I don't plan to be here forever to have another career.
But it's certainly a good thing to do on the days that I am.
It's a real honor and a real privilege. Thank you so much for this opportunity. It's just a lovely view. Thank you.
Thank you.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.